so i want to do a video about the government
debt and government cuts because recently i
did an interview on the radio where they said
that we can't afford TFL we have to close the
Bakerloo line we can't afford obviously the train
to Leeds that's been cancelled and we can't afford
the cost of the NHS then we can't afford the cost
of social care and the reason given for this is
because the government debt has increased now
i would encourage anyone who hasn't watched it
to watch the first video on this channel which
is about the finances of Covid-19 because the
government debt increased massively during Covid
19 but the government printed that money and it
was given out and ended up sitting in the bank
account of wealthy individuals so whilst the
government debt has increased by £450 billion
billionaire wealth has increased by £106billion
which is a quarter of the amount and the
rest is being held by wealthy individuals so i
want people to remember that that government debt
is not to nobody it is to the wealthy individuals
of this country and there has been an equivalent
increase in the wealth of wealthy individuals now
if you watch that video the finance of Covid-19
you'll see a year and a half ago i predicted that
there'd be a massive increase in billionaire and
wealthy individual wealth that would push up house
prices and it would push up inflation and push up
the government debt it's exactly what has happened
and what i said at the time was that may be used
to justify cutting services for ordinary people
and raising taxes on ordinary people
which is again exactly what has happened
taxes on ordinary people have been raised
so what i want you to do is to connect
the government debt to the increased wealth of
wealthy individuals we talk about this in the what
is wealth video that the debt of the government is
also the wealth of wealthy individuals so what we
have had here is covered has essentially been used
to increase government debt but also make the rich
enormously richer it has been the biggest ever in
all of history single year increase in billionaire
and super rich wealth and what this means is
all of these things we're told we can't afford
it's only because the government has transferred
an enormous amount of wealth to the richest in
our society if we tax that wealth back we can
afford all the things that we as a society need
if we don't tax it back then number one we
can't afford those things and number two
ordinary people like you will have to pay more
taxes from your salaries and what we see now is
the chancellor who is a billionaire cutting tax on
billionaires raising tax on ordinary people making
billionaire wealth increase by more than it's
ever increased in the past and at the same time
raising your taxes so the main thing
to understand here the debt of the
government has only increased by as much as
the wealth of the super rich has increased
we can get that back if we choose to tax
the richest and if we don't then we can't
and it will have to be taxed on the rest of
us and cuts to our services. happy with that?
but poorer families will be forced
to lose almost all of the assets
including their home we have a tax system which is
very efficient attacking ordinary working people
but very inefficient attacks in the super rich